now youo Parson into the goal line getting
it back from Nyquist Kier guarded up top by
Belmar Parson in a shot caught off by grower
twice and play comes to a halt right pad right
out in front here this one hits guar up high and
he got to fight off Novak on the rebound as well
Gus Nyquist Nashville has about 15 seconds
left on this power play finally back into
the Zone here sizin out of the box Evangelista
settles back for Barry Evangelista to the goal
line out in front they score Tommy Novak got a
brilliant pass from Colton szin at the goal line
it's a power play goal with two seconds left on
the penalty to Adam lson one- nothing Nashville
Nashville's able to get set up with Novak Siz
behind the net and it's just a quick little po
play Play Down Low it will work its way down to
the bottom sizin Novak into the back of the net
here tough to do when it's a tap OneTouch passing
on the tape the whole way you have to respect the
shooter low no back right on his onetime side and
into the back of the net as the Kraken sorted out
York Strand will take it downstairs on trennan
rim it all the way back for Jared mccan mccan
goes deeper in the zone and back for Schultz this
way Bor strand a shot he scores to the Maestro
it's a power play goal for Oliver Bor Strand and
the Kraken have tied it for the Seattle Kraken
very good movement mccan going all the way down
by the goal line but look how high borran comes
up to get this pass from Schulz and a rist shot
from there he's able to beat the outstretched
stick of trenin bar down into the back of the ne
great screen out in front by wber but again it's
just great movement you get the puck on and off
the stick here from Bor sh who said last season
with his new team it took him a while to get
some footing he was so great in the second half
brilliant in the playoffs he's off to a toret
start toen and denied by Soros greeted there
by Will borgan out of that cluster reset by McAn
look out Liam py good stick by Gord on forsburg
jailbreak Kraken gourd with mccan who opens up and
scores Jared mccan that's hockey baby two to one
[Music] Seattle on Stick disrupts
the plate of forsberg a clearcut
two onone does allow the pass to get
through you want to take away either
the pass or the shooter if your loads on
he allows the pass to to go through one
time he's in there Tommy Novak
to the point man Tyson Barry
Jeremy loan Novak one-time Barry Kicks
save Gau gets the rebound off Jeremy
loon rubow continues to move exceptionally well
here tonight goow on in tight quarters thwarted
Standing Tall one-time opportunity from the
blue line gets this Puck through here comes
the the second shot gets a pad out but LS on
finding that lane not able to get through he'll
be back here in March Nyquist cuts the pass
broken up by Schwarz Nyquist in front great
stick by dun on Ryan O'Reilly O'Reilly out
in front grow what a save on Nyquist Mercy
Riley out in front and that's a post here's Post
Number Two off the side of the net actually for n
whis off the draw wiberg for Dunn here's Larson
his shot bought off by Soros a couple of times
Larson the followup Everly stopped by Soros
Everly goes and gets another opportunity as
well but here's the first two looks at lson
jumping up into that play and then it becomes
he goes hard at Roman Yosi the Swiss born
defenseman moves the puck it's left there
Barry sweeps it held in by alexc just by bers
Bor stret for the short side Zoros had none
of it trying to find Matty bener is not able
to Corral that puck but it goes off the board
strong like Bor Shan's opportunity Novak Nyquist
right now on the periphery Yosi with a shot goes
wide off the end boards and now nqu gets to it
Novak and back of the goal in front grow said
no on szin Tyson Barry to the wall for Yosi he'll
walk it in he draws gourd as a Defender now Barry
at the line surveys top of the ring in back
forsberg Barry onetime Yosi scores Roman Yosi
before Philip guow could react to it 326 left to
go in the second period it's a power play goal
the game is tied you don't see it too often where
there's two defensemen there anymore and this is
one of those instances you Barry at the point
sending this Puck over for the one-time super
Mo right there posting in can really get a hold
of that puck on the one-time wi it's set up like
that just beating the glove there of Philip guau
Roman Yosi as a defenseman has led this team in
scoring four straight seas and hean forsburg are
at the top of all kinds of scoring statistical
categories in their franchise history an expansion
team that dates back to 1998 now it's moved all
the way around bork strand lets it Go Schult
swings it here's Duman dlan with a shoty scor
pick up the phone it's answer time dial number
eight Brian Duman 32 Seattle keep in by Schultz
over to Duman net front traffic cier SOS is not
able to see this Puck great shot by dumin changes
the angle dragging it shooting it in but it's
that net front screen you can see SOS does not
know I would just think the goalie is trying to
make a save I don't think he's thinking okay I'm
going to trip the guy now but who knows Yosi now
in control moved along for Nyquist a shot bought
off the rebound grow comes up big on no back and
Philip guow Standing Tall well that was an amazing
save right there but the second opport by Novak
has to fully extend and stretch out right after
taking that contact why they're short-handed
but this Save Right Here tells me grar is ready
was off the Stick of Seattle's Adam Larson he's
back on it he'll move it for Jaden Schwarz bers
on the gallop he and bork strand matd in the
zone pulls in shoot stopped by Soros off of a
wall play by Schwarz O'Reilly just the last
second now Nashville busting back the other
way night qust for forsburg Yosi alone he'll
delay in front grow says no cruising through as
nightquest play it off the boards intended for
Larsson read by Novak and Adam Larson hustles
back beautifully here come the Kracken wiberg's
in a shot stopped by Soros and Yosi cleans up
the rebound just two more real world examples
Vin stun scores off a Faceoff win 42 [Music]
Seattle face off so important what do you do
when you win Vince dun quickly hammers the puck
towards the net doesn't waste time good battle
there by Schwarz two players in scissons and I
believe forber stepping in the way to try to
block that puck but goes right underneath the
arm a centering pass tonight grow of Parson in
46 seconds left you'll see guarded by bork strand
bar shot kicked out twice by Gau Parson again at
the top of the crease two10 of his second put up
on the clock 2.4 off the draw guau takes care of
it that's Kraken hockey [Applause] [Music] baby